all right what's going on guys this is
rob and let's talk about obi-wan kenobi
episode number three specifically let's
talk about the duel between
darth vader and obi-wan kenobi because i
feel like this is a big point of
division among star wars fans it seems
pretty divisive i was doing a little bit
of reading online after i saw the
episode and people either loved it or
they hated it not a whole lot of people
are in between i'm in the camp where i
loved it because this highlighted just
one incredible aspect of these two guys
which is how far they've fallen and
that's what's so incredible about this i
mean this fight really is by all
standards of measurement a battle just
between two old fogies right like obi
bum kenobi and darth vader who is anakin
skywalker
minus like 60 of his power i'm just
throwing out a random number just to get
the point across but nowhere near as
powerful as he used to be comparable to
obi-wan kenobi in a lot of different
ways in terms of abilities and so this
is this is one of the things that i
think really makes this episode so
fantastic honestly because nothing else
does right like what else happens in
this episode like they fight some
stormtroopers and like some chick shows
up dressed as a sith officer and it's
like we're kind of helping to smuggle
people to safety
and like that's it right there's a droid
that's there that i kind of wish had
been hk47 and like that's really all you
have right there's really nothing else
and it's princess leia running away yet
again only to presumably be captured
maybe kind of i guess whatever at the
end of the episode so so here's the
thing right here's here's like the the
meat and potatoes of this
this illustrates that the force is not
some infinite source of power it is but
it can be diminished in an individual
person and this is something that unless
you're familiar with the continuity
outside of well really the expanded
universe to be quite frank uh it's not
something that you'd readily be aware of
right so let's talk about that for a
second let's talk about the diminishing
ability to use the force so there's two
different aspects of this right there is
what's seemingly the natural progression
which is to say over time
jedi and sith their ability to use the
force has just gotten weaker over time
which is the reason why as cool and
powerful as palpatine is i would say in
the face of like darth bane or anybody
like that guy would get absolutely
massacred right he would just wouldn't
stand a chance uh you look at somebody
like anakin skywalker sure he's really
powerful xr [ __ ] would crush that guy
right i mean i'm i stand firm right i
will die on this mountain that those
guys would crush any of the modern jedi
save for maybe legends luke right luke
from the from the old legends series but
even then i think it's a bit of a
stretch having said that there's also
the diminishing ability to use the force
during what's basically the prequel
series now the reason why that happened
is not really a natural progression of
things it was actually manipulation
external manipulation from a couple
different places as i understand it the
first one which was covered in the book
of tarkin is basically that the jedi
temple on coruscant was built over an
old sith shrine and that was used by
palpatine to basically flood the the
jedi temple for lack of a better phrase
with the the dark side of the force
basically clouding everything right it
was quite literally like filling the
building with fog right with like you
know smoke or something like that nobody
can see anything that's going on that's
kind of what it was what the temple was
doing or what the shrine was doing on a
more metaphysical level regarding the
force the other part of it is that
palpatine actually had a device that
would mask his force signature from the
other jedi which is the reason why
unless he just kind of said something
just seemed a little weird right like
that sounds like something a sith would
say the jedi wouldn't really have any
knowledge that he was a sith lord i mean
there were a couple times right you guys
remember there was some statement he
made and yoda gave him the stink eye and
it was like okay so obviously there's
something going on with this guy the
jedi might pick up on it it's like nope
never mind they're idiots like they're
never going to figure it out but
honestly it was because that little
device that palpatine had that just
basically masked that you would think
just because he looked suspicious i mean
the guy looked shady right like it's
almost like you don't even need to be a
jedi right the jedi are like all right
things are a little off here let's just
hire a random detective and the random
detective is just like okay i figured it
out that guy over there that chancellor
who is obviously a bad guy because he
just looks the part that guy's the sith
lord you're hunting for right i mean
like i'm surprised you didn't figure
this out on your own right but
nonetheless right it's just it's just
one of those things but again when it
comes to jedi and sith they just kind of
naturally lose the ability to use the
force as time goes on or have naturally
become weaker as time has gone on but
this is doubly so with somebody like
obi-wan kenobi because one of the things
to understand about the force is it's
like a muscle it will atrophy if you go
long enough without using it because
having the force you know it's one thing
to be able to tap into the force right
to be able to say like i am a force
sensitive person there's a lot of people
out there who are force sensitive anakin
skywalker as a little kid was force
sensitive but just because a person can
use the force does not mean that they
are a capable force user they have to be
trained to do that it's a skill set and
that if you don't use that skill set
after a while you'll start forgetting
things it's like being a bodybuilder
right i mean you could have perfect
squat form but if you go on long enough
eventually you'll lose that form you
won't be able to squat as well you could
potentially injure yourself now there
may be some kind of muscle memory that
goes into that but the force is uh is a
finicky thing and so there's nothing to
really even guarantee that if obi-wan
kenobi were to start tapping into the
force again then suddenly you know he
becomes celine dion right it's all
coming back all coming back to me now
you know what i mean like it's not
there's no guarantee it's going to be
that way and so what you saw here in
this episode
was a great depiction of what happens
when you've got obi bum kenobi who is
lost or his connection to the force has
been drastically diminished facing off
against darth vader who is a fraction or
has a fraction of the power that anakin
skywalker had now the next thing goes
into like the just the presence right
like when they were there and what they
were doing so i feel like one of the
best things that highlights this is when
darth vader shows up on this little
backwater planet and just starts hunting
for obi-wan but if this was anakin
skywalker in episode three he would have
found obi-wan like that right when he
was literally kind of hiding over there
he would have just been like there you
are and just like like just force
grabbed him or something like that done
something to indicate he knows exactly
where he is right pinpoint his location
perfectly but he didn't do that because
his connection to the force is
diminished instead he just walked
through the town knocked some boxes out
of the way the show you know to show
that he knew there were people hiding
there but he didn't know that they were
obi-wan kenobi and then like force
choked a couple of folks because darth
vader's not as powerful as anakin was if
that was anakin skywalker that was like
pre-vader anakin skywalker he would have
killed everybody and probably just in
just one grandiose motion right just
like use the force and just shut down
the brains of everybody or something
crazy right it just would have been like
damn that's how much more powerful
that's like how powerful he's become now
with the dark side that's kind of the
irony of like darth vader and the whole
anakin skywalker dichotomy when it comes
to emperor palpatine is because sure the
bargain that was made between palpatine
and anakin is well we'll find some way
to save the life of padme but the
unofficial bargain that was struck by
anakin was
the dark side of the force is more
powerful than the light side of the
force and he even made that statement to
ob1 at one point right like the dark
side is more powerful just unbridled use
of the force no limitations use it
however you want to just go out and have
a good time that's basically how it
works right you don't have like you're
not limited by like the code of the jedi
using the force only for defense never
for offense that kind of thing right
it's just use it as you please
and hopefully you can live right and
that's basically it but the the whole
thing that happened here is when anakin
became darth vader he became weaker so
that's kind of the funny thing right
that's kind of the funny situation that
you look at there had anakin skywalker
let's say for example he had
successfully killed obi-wan kenobi on
mustafar and had been elevated to the
position of darth vader oh he would have
become drastically it would it would
have been insane how powerful he'd
become especially when you read the
darth vader comics and you find out that
he's just doing things secretly right if
like the force unleashed were brought
into continuity like his own apprentice
gail and merrick right going through and
having like his own jedi apprentice or
his own set apprentice who was just
crazy powerful like doing things in
secret anakin would have found sources
of power out there that would have
helped him or elevated him to a position
beyond palpatine he would have killed
palpatine and then taken his place and
then taken his own apprentice right so
that would have been well within the
power of anakin such as it is he's his
connection his power is drastically
diminished and that goes into the
lightsaber battles right a lot of people
are kind of looking at that and they're
just like i mean these two guys just
look totally enfeebled right i mean
there's these two these these old dudes
essentially or at least one who whose
connection to the force is severely
diminished due to his machine components
and the other one whose connection is
diminished just due to a lack of use
these guys they're just kind of fumbling
and bumbling around with lightsabers in
the desert it's like of course they are
they're nowhere near as powerful as they
used to be right i mean that's like
saying look at how they fight in episode
four god man those guys this this is not
how lightsaber duels are supposed to be
no it kind of is right because this what
you saw here segways perfectly into
episode four and it's a great way to
answer that question how do you go from
obi-wan kenobi and pre-vader anakin
skywalker in episode 3 with these just
incredible ballets in terms of their
lightsaber duels and so on and so forth
to how they are now the reality is that
was all viable because of the force that
having like these crazy displays in
terms of like movements being able to
move so fluidly and all that kind of
stuff that's all for stuff right like
being able to utilize all those
different lightsaber forms is because of
the force when you take that away of
course they're basically just a couple
of people who are just just swinging at
each other in the desert right they
literally look like larpers right just
live-action role-playing they look they
look like star wars guy right just out
there in a field fighting against each
other
and i loved seeing it because that's
exactly what i expected to see from two
guys whose connection to the force is
drastically diminished that even with
darth vader using the lightsaber
one-handed it's like okay so he's trying
to capture the glory of days gone by but
it's obvious he's not anakin skywalker
anymore he doesn't have the same level
of power as anakin skywalker anymore the
funny thing is it looks like anakin just
hasn't figured that out yet he still
thinks he's as capable as he ever was he
hasn't learned the huge limitations that
are imposed on him now because he's more
machine than man twisted and evil so
it's a cool thing but i loved that fight
i loved the way it looked it just
perfectly highlighted how far these two
guys have fallen in their relation to
the force and their capabilities by
virtue of the force so with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end let me know what you think down
in the comments section about the whole
episode 3 darth vader all that kind of
stuff let me know what you all think and
i will catch you all later
peace